congressman will heard of Texas is one
of three african-american Republicans in
Congress he is a member of the House
Homeland Security Committee and Select
Committee on Intelligence he joins us
from his hometown of San Antonio
congressman Hurd good morning good
morning I know you've said that
President Trump needs to apologize it
doesn't appear that he plans to do that
he's doubled down what happens to happen
next well I think everybody needs to
realize that the outrage that's some of
the comments that that he said has
caused is because you're trying to
equate neo-nazis and skinheads and
anti-semites to people that were trying
to stand up against hate that that is
the problem and the leader of the free
world should be unambiguous in the
opposition to these to racism bigotry
and anti-semitism and and we also have
to realize you know I have to tell
people all the time we didn't elect an
emperor we elected a president and the
Republican Party is broader than just a
one individual no congressman if these
things continue where are they leading
us what's the possibility I to be honest
I I don't know but but what we it should
be very clear that everybody should be
against against racism against bigotry
you know the fact that the leader of the
Senate had to put out a statement to say
that there are no good neo you know
neo-nazis you know is is problematic and
what we should be talking about is what
you know does the federal resources or
our federal law enforcement and state
law enforcement have the resources to
deal with some of these problems in the
future
what let's talk about radicalization and
why have some of these people that
showed up to Charlottesville why have
they gotten to that point why do they
believe the way that they believe so
that we can try to prevent this in the
future and you know I spent nine and a
half years as an undercover officer in
the CIA and in most of my
most of my career was chasing terrorists
and dealing with evil and you have to
deal with evil head-on and these are the
Congress kind of conversations we should
be having right now not whether or not
there are good you know people going to
Klan rallies do you think congressman
that the people that hold these white
supremacist views now feel more
emboldened vices done an incredible
documentary where the people back in the
day you would at least try to hide your
identity in some kind of way and I was
looking at this documentary the other
day very disturbing were you saying more
people are gonna die we are right and
they are wrong what can we do about that
and it does how much does it concern you
well well it concerns me that it's 2017
you and there's still people that have
these feelings and for those that
haven't watched that vice news piece
please do it really is a brilliant piece
of journalism and and what you know I
just completed 27 stops throughout my
district I call it the DC 2dq tour where
I go as many dairy queens as I can and
and one of the things that that I
learned from from that is there's way
more that unites us than divides us as
Americans those are the things that we
should we should be talking about not
the issues that are dividing us and I
think it requires elected leaders and
political leaders to speak up on behalf
of those things that that do unite us
remember that we're all Americans first
and we have to have a sober review of
the radicalization process that gets
someone to this point where they feel
like it's okay to carry a torch or poke
women with a with a flagpole
congressman beyond words I mean what
does what does the president need to do
and what does the country need to do
right now beyond words and beyond
apologist which are necessary well look
at what I just said let's focus on what
unites us not what divides us let's you
know we have to transcend D or R and
actually focus on problems that are
going to help our country this is you
know we we are consuming ourselves
trying to sign whether someone's right
or someone's wrong on from a political
argument there are some basic things be
kind to one another
all right you know treat people with
respect
be honest you notice all those things
that we learned in kindergarten are
still are still valuable today and I
think we need we all need to take a deep
breath and reset thanks congressman